[Musique]
il n'y aura pas de passation de pouvoir
cette année après l'élection
présidentielle puisque emmanuel macron a
été réélu pour un second mandat au
programme seulement une cérémonie
d'investiture et dans l'histoire de la
vème république c'est arrivé plusieurs
fois
le 21 mai 1988 françois mitterrand est
officiellement investi président de la
république après avoir battu jacques
chirac au second tour de la
présidentielle pas de passation de
pouvoir une cérémonie d'investiture très
simple à l'elysée les résultats de
l'élection sont proclamés par le
président du conseil constitutionnel
françois mitterrand reçoit le collier de
grand maître de l'ordre de la légion
d'honneur les honneurs militaires lui
sont rendus dans le jardin de l'elysée
et puis le président de la république
prononce son discours d'investiture avec
un objectif ne pas braquer les électeurs
de droite qui ont voté pour jacques
chirac ce mois de mai 1988 n'a pas vu
les bons l'emporter sur les méchants
ni le grand trail c'est en somme la
victoire de la république qui nous faut
ensemble assurer la république
n'appartient à personne
nous en sommes tous des titres
différents les garants et les artisans
autre élection présidentielle sans
passation de pouvoir celle de jacques
chirac en 2002 réélu dans un contexte
très particulier puisque pour la
première fois le candidat du front
national jean marie le pen arrive au
second tour de la présidentielle jacques
chirac a donc été élu grâce aux voix des
électeurs de gauche qui ont fait barrage
à l'extrême droite alors forcément son
discours d'investiture s'adresse à eux
au nom de l'intérêt général
[Musique]
rassembler c'est souvent l'objectif des
discours d'investiture des présidents de
la république et c'est ce qui avait
voulu faire emmanuel macron en 2017 il
avait eu un mot pour chacun de ses
prédécesseurs je songe au général de
gaulle qui oeuvra pour redresser la
france et lui rendre son rang dans le
concert des nations
je songe à georges pompidou qui fit de
notre pays une puissance industrielle
majeure
à valéry giscard d'estaing qui sut
ferrand très la france et sa société
dans la modernité
à françois mitterrand qui accompagna la
réconciliation du rêve français et du
rêve européen
à jacques chirac nous donnons le rang
d'une nation sachant dire non aux
prétentions des va-t-en guerre
à nicolas sarkozy
ne comptant pas son énergie pour
résoudre la crise financière qui avait
si violemment frappé le monde
et je songe bien sûr à françois hollande
faisant oeuvre de précurseur avec
l'accord de paris sur le climat et
protégeant les français dans un monde
frappés par le terrorisme
cette année la cérémonie d'investiture
des manuels macron sera organisée avant
le 13 mai jour de fin de son premier
mandat
[Musique]